if you love comic books and you love
film you have Sin City because since it
is perfect synthesis of both and it
requires a team to do that and that team
begins with two people I'm going to
bring them out now they are Robert
Rodriguez and Frank Miller
great memories
so Robert I have a question for you it
used to be when Hollywood decided to
make a movie out of a comic book they
would start by saying how do we fix this
how do we adapt it how many do I think
they thought it was broken - in some
ways like it would lose a lot of the
things that made it what it was well I
think people would think that you know
there are two different mediums you know
comics and then there were movies and
that they were completely different so
you would have to adapt it into a movie
and when I would see the work especially
Frank Miller where he's the writer and
the creator of the visuals I saw that he
was doing the most groundbreaking
original breathtaking visual
storytelling that I had seen in any
medium and I couldn't understand why you
couldn't just translate that to the
screen rather than try and take that
book and turn it into a movie why not
take movies and turn it into Frank's
work so that's what the whole Sin City
was about it was actually ten years ago
most of the day that we were here to
show the first footage about eight
months before it came out and y'all were
the first people to see it and support
it and say wow that's that's really
different this is the question who was
here ten years ago to see that original
city that was I remember him it changed
it was a new way to look at cinema and a
way to look at technology and a way to
look at comic books and graphic novels
and and I think that's why things kind
of changed I think for the better Frank
says that yeah I think that um that the
comic book movies have been coming out
have been getting better because they've
been closer to the source material
there's it's one thing to sit down on a
drawing board and create something out
of whole cloth and and and write it and
how do your completely here vision and
and and then you know be willing to test
it on a relatively small market and a
completely different thing to take you
know some existing character and throw
them into a board room full of a bunch
of people who
think that comic books are crap and and
and turn out something that really
proves they candy that's the studio
that's exciting you know Frank as the
complic
since I was reading you know it's been
fascinating to watch the journey of your
art and your your your body of work it
seems to me in a way you're almost like
on a Picasso like journey trying to like
deconstruct the action on the page or I
hope you agree or else I don't look
really stupid but we do you agree you
don't well I actually the way I started
seeing City was a first in my career
because one thing I always wanted to do
crime stories and when I first came into
comics they would only publish stories
about guys in tights so I had always had
to draw them and I'm working as many him
you know crime elements as I could but
then because of my work on Batman and
other other projects I was invited to
invited become a screenwriter and I was
not happy with the process at all there
was too many bosses being a screenwriter
is I mean a screenplay is kind of kind
of like a fire hydrant with all the dogs
going all right around the block lining
up for it so I moved away and sat down
and decided to create the comic book
that could not be adapted to the movies
it was Sin City the first thing I did
was go up to Frank and say hey could I
turn this into a movie it's really cool
yeah this crazy Texan shows up he shows
me how to do it it's fantastic all right
well you know we want to bring out we're
gonna go now let's watch the hey you
know so a little bit about the what I'm
gonna show
yeah what's great about i mean who here
is familiar with a story just another
Saturday night you know this that's the
Sin City short story we start the movie
with that as an introduction to Marv and
if you know the book there's just some
really bold visual storytelling going on
and I wish we could show you this in 3d
it's still three still being worked on
but it's stunning in 3d because you
really get immersed into what Frank did
but the visual language is there so I'm
gonna show you like we did ten years ago
I'm gonna show you the opening you know
part of the opening scene I want to show
you all the opening single stop it at a
certain point I'm going to bring out
some of the cast the amazing Gail played
by rosario Dawson Dwight McCarthy from
dame to kill for played by Josh Brolin
Nancy Callahan Jessica Alba
hello welcome everybody welcome to Hall
H all H says hello Jessica I'll start
with you if it's okay returning to this
world and seeing those visuals on the
screen and like it's a very distinctive
very singular universe that must be
pretty satisfying for you to to have a
return ticket yeah I feel like the
luckiest girl in Hollywood it's great
and then your character has Nancy has a
lot in this movie and there's a well I
want to say too much about it but it's
it's it takes through some places that
if people haven't read the book they're
gonna be a little surprised yeah I mean
it's an original story that Frank and
Robert developed I sort of got to
participate in that as well over the
last decade Nancy was so sweet and she
was sort of a victim in the first one so
I think and this one that people will be
pleasantly surprised to see her turn
into a warrior thank Josh welcome how
are you sir I'm good I wanted to play
Nancy but it didn't work out sorry the
Wardrobe tryout that was the that's what
killed you know there's the Wardrobe
what's a you know for you coming into
this and we were talking about how
you've gone to some pretty dark places
in movies there's some EQ some nice
violence what was it about Frank
Miller's work and Roberts work and and
the Sin City universe that really
connected with you well I mean you don't
necessarily know it connects with you
until you're into it first of all it's
really nice to be asked to be a part of
the second of all
you know I've known Robert for 21 years
so we've worked together and we knew
each other and we enjoyed each other's
company at work and then thirdly and
most important you're dealing with two
total iconoclast guys who really don't
beat to anybody's drum like what what
Frank said you know a screenplay as a as
a hydrant with wood with a bunch of dogs
waiting to piss on it there that's Frank
Miller for you
unapologetically himself and that to be
involved with somebody like that is
wonderful because you don't really you
know Robert doesn't take what Frank does
and makes it really his own even though
he does in a way you really have to dive
into what he's created and I think
that's what differentiates this from a
lot of other adaptations and that's
really nice to be involved in something
not original that's fantastic
and then Rosario as far as the the sense
of place in Sin City and the districts
within it there it's a real geography a
landscape and it makes the characters
even more iconic the archetypal than
they are in a way mm-hmm I mean you you
have that these neighborhoods that are
segmented and and people who are kind of
cut off from each other and and it it's
amazing when you can kind of go through
and you're like okay so here you're in
the projects here you're in Sin City
here you this and it kind of helps you
to see what type of people gravitate
towards one place or the other and
things always happen when you get a
little lost when you get off the beaten
path and you go someplace different and
you encounter different people and I
think that that geography and going
around that is helpful to kind of really
feel the essence of sensitive being a
real place you know you're not just
there and it's never Neverland or
something like that like you actually
feel like maybe it's around the corner
and it's down that dark alley and maybe
I'll actually meet these people it gives
it a sense even as outrageous and as
full-on and and over that you know sort
of over the threshold of anything else
you've ever experienced before you still
do feel it said that there's an essence
of it like this could be realized people
could be my neighbors and for all three
of you it feels to like this could
there's a it's anachronistic in a way
that it the dialogue is of another time
in a way it speaks to a different type
of filmmaking and
crime stories and things that must be
kind of fun you don't get to probably do
that bad often in Hollywood these days
it's how Robert talks all the time you
can't really naturalize that kind of
dialogue you have to become its cadence
which is great because a minute you know
usually in movies you're trying to
naturalize things and make it really
seem seamless and you can't in this so
when you're doing it you don't know if
it's gonna turn out okay and then you
see it and if you don't do it properly
Robert will come up in oh just do it
like your voice down like that's bad
those are the best to have like Frank
come up and be like this is actually how
I always envisioned it or how I wrote
this line or this is the texture to it
you know to be able to have you there
and have you there and it'd be just as
much as we feel like it's cool and it's
amazing to be a part of it was great to
see how giddy the both of you would get
like I remember when we first worked out
walked out 10 years ago and the outfits
and Frank's face was like I drew you in
the dark by myself a very long time ago
and here you are walking out to say
hello to me this is crazy and then
Robert coming up and going here you are
again and you are Gayle I recognize you
as Gayle but you're saying different
things you're wearing something
different like what is happening here
this is just so it becomes so alive and
I think that's what that language does
as well as makes it very alive and makes
it very Concord like this place that's
really real space and I think it gives
it a class and an energy that otherwise
if we were trying to modernize it or
something would just get lost it would
become just it would actually soften it
yeah yeah metropolis it is not yeah
what's wrong it's not something that was
the fun of it it was we'd go and so I'd
be operating the camera a lot of times
it'd be right there with the actor we'd
do a performance that we thought was it
but we really want to get Frank sign off
so we'd run back very excited to see
what his reaction is and we knew we had
it if we go back there and you get this
huge grin on his face you know Frank
doesn't win very often so we had a big
grin on his face
you knew you'd nailed it and that was
exciting thing cos he's dreamt it so
long ago never expecting to see it acted
and performed and it gives you
goosebumps you know when you hear a very
iconic line like Dwight's saying never
let the monster out or something like
that is something he had only wrote and
drew never thought he would hear and see
it come to life in such a great way that
was always the goal was make Frank you
know really happy with seeing this come
to life in the right way and you've
always championed keeping the film
franchise rooted and tethered to that
heritage and that legacy and and and
putting making sure that Frank's name is
in the title and things like that and
that that comes from your fan affection
for the works I love the work I knew
what a singular work it was I wanted it
to be Frank Miller's Sin City actually
made that the title so that when you
looked it up it would have his name
first because it was such an amazing
work I really wanted to perform more as
a facilitator than a director as far as
oh thank you as far as making sure that
this was very true to the source
material that was brilliant work and
Hollywood didn't get it back then the
directors guild didn't get it when I
tried to explain that he was already a
storyteller he was just using a pen
instead of a camera but it was he was
doing the most bold breathtaking visual
storytelling and we try to emulate that
with a film it was an IMAX pen I think
it's got a big vision in it
yeah I have to say it wasn't the first
time when I remember showing up on set
and sit the level that you were taking
it to to make to immortalize this work
and using the comic as a storyboard down
to the angle the level of where the
camera would be so the actual
perspective which was unusual but that
would be true to exactly what your
vision of was where you would actually
go can kind of go a little bit more to
the right raise your arm this way
because he had sketches of the
characters put into the monitor so he
could actually position you in the exact
position that Frank had drawn it that
like level like it just brought and they
brought everyone up to the same sort of
level of excitement of just going wow
this has never been done before this is
amazing
it's awesome and as you say positions it
reminds me ray Liotta's in this movie
and as is Christopher Lloyd and by I was
thinking arrays scene where he's in a we
see a lot of rain oh this though the you
see that the opening under dame to kill
for the way it's drawn it was so
incredibly drawn we really try to
emulate the lighting the framing and if
you familiar with the book we I think we
really nail it with the casting of Ray
and and and everybody who showed up
there's a huge cast if he and Stacy
Keach Chris Meloni Jerry Piven or
Christopher Lloyd people bring the skill
other characters to life besides these
people up here and you're gonna be
really surprised and thrilled Eva Green
who does an incredible job as the Dame
an incredible job at the same you mean
she brings that super you know to life
and in 3d and will blow you away we
couldn't have been you know it's taking
a long time to get to the screen but I
don't think any other time would have
been the right time like now this cast
would not have been there we started
actually shooting before we even had the
full cast the first person we shot was
Jessica and she came in so prepared so
really set the bar of what the
performances were gonna be like I think
that's what I was most surprised by was
how even though everyone was great in
the first film it really was a very
early for green screen people didn't
really know what green screen was back
then digital photography was very new
back then so people knew what they were
doing this time they'd already seen the
film they already knew what this world
was gonna be the performances are ten
times better under times better than the
first film cuz everyone knew what they
were doing and started with Jessica then
Mickey and then Josh became available he
dropped in you know we were casting as
we were shooting so we got that amazing
cast just on faith that they would show
up and their schedules would work out
and it caused some pretty funny things
like when Josh showed up his schedule
became open he was our first choice for
Dwight and he wasn't available when we
started shooting but by the time we got
to his section he was available but with
with a catch he showed up and he goes
where's Mickey aren't all my scenes with
Mickey go oh we shot him last month
who how does that work he carries me
around he's driving me around we're
drinking together I know it's the green
screen I was doing here and they never
met he was I've been wanting to work
with Vicki for twenty years and now I'm
working with him and he's not here well
kind of be there there's a monitor
you'll get to see what he does what was
that like it was really kind of cool
because you connected watch a scene and
go wow Mickey's really funny in this I
can't do that at all I got to go the
other way and you would balance the
performances out it was really pretty
cool you know where I got that from why
I worked with her Carlo Montalban and he
told me how I told him how amazing he
was in Wrath of Khan and he goes I did
that all by myself he said I I was
acting will Shannon wasn't there yet I
had to perform completely and then he
watched my footage later and did his
performance and at the premiere he said
thank you for your performance cuz I got
to watch it and then I acted against
that he goes well I didn't have anything
so you got to do that watching Mickey
and then performing against it as if he
was there was that like I from that
moment on I only do movies by myself now
it works I mean I we were talking
Rosario and I were talking about this
before it you know you you taught you
know being an actor or whatever that is
that you want to connect with your with
the person that you're acting with and
how much that means and all that and
then Robert Rodriguez just blew that to
smithereens because we watch the movie
you don't know how the movie especially
when you do green-screen you don't know
how the movie is going to turn out so
it's like well how does it feel well it
feels totally alien it feels totally
foreign and you're really entrusting the
director and and the directors in this
instance to to create something
wonderful so I'm on a cliff with you
know the skyline amazing skyline and you
know city lights in the background and
really I'm on a green floor with the car
next to me and I don't
I don't even know I mean I did I just
kind of gave up it was a big blackout
for me but then when you watch the movie
you go oh my god I mean this this is you
really get to experience the motive as
if you've never read the script it's so
it's such an original bizarre alien
experience that you create as you say
that it sounds almost like a black box
theater I mean it sounds like a you know
sort of a classic actors challenge of
choice really is and you have to be more
focused I mean that's the thing is it's
how is it you know you have to lend
yourself way more to your imagination
than you normally would which puts you
further into somebody like Frank
Miller's mind you know you can't
Frank Miller sucks you into it you can't
make it come to you you have to lend
yourself to it otherwise it doesn't work
I don't think Frank you've had so much
success in comic books it's hard to even
begin to sum it up but writing the two
greatest at least the two greatest
Batman stories I mean Batman year one
and and The Dark Knight Returns thank
you see they got the movie titles right
and so they picked up the Dark Knight
that was good but it's with Sin City
these are Cuba this isn't daredevil
which with the great daredevil run you
did and creating a lecture and all that
but these are characters that sprung
from you yeah does that make them
especially different in a way to you do
you do you feel more protective of them
than say Greece weighing on I feel very
protective about every character I've
worked on but on creating characters had
a whole sloths a whole different
experience and when I was working on Sin
City I was after a particular when I was
first drawing I was asked a particular
tone and a particular feeling I knew I
wanted that antiquated way of talking
where women would be referred to his
games and such and I had you know no
intention of seeing it on you know on
the big screen what I think really on
emerged in the making of the set of the
second movie was that the whole world
who saw it actually got used to the
world of Sin City and accepted for what
it was and so everybody from me from the
audience to to the chaps camión that
much more comfortable with with the kind
of dialogue that I'd written and and and
and so when you know when Jessica showed
up she was already you know I went over
to say hi to her and and she barely said
hello to me because she was already in
character and ready to do a graveyard
scene when Rosario showed up she so
owned the character that I had almost
nothing to say except thank you and and
try on the executioner to master sorry I
was so funny when she showed up she was
shooting another movie and so in the
first film she came in and she was like
I'll do anything you need she shaved her
head into a mohawk to look like the
character and this one they'd stay said
ahead of time she can't do anything
really radical with her hair because
she's filming another movie so no okay
so villain and then we tied it up we try
to make it look like the thing and I'm
thinking in the back of my head audience
doesn't going to understand that that's
why she can't do it they're gonna
probably things she didn't go all the
way and she does just rosario goes all
the way with her performance the next
morning she showed up on set with her
head shaved like that herself
you know like half Hazzard Lee done and
said what did you do your hair she goes
I was walking around my hotel room last
night I thought I don't want people to
think I didn't bring it this time
it's okay we'll go try and fix it it's a
little crooked and look she's still she
brings it but I love that you thought of
that without me mentioning it I don't
think I didn't bring it in Jessica what
was that like you came a completely
different person when you showed up and
you set the bar you prepared you created
the choreography you came in and you
were someone else and I pulled you aside
a few times because Mickey Rourke gave
you props and I said Mickey Rourke never
gives props he just said how amazing you
are this Bruce Willis gave you major
props there was something going on this
time what was it about this time because
I didn't get to ask you that it was it
stunned Assad it set the bar for all the
performances that came what was its like
this time around what were you thinking
gosh well I hadn't you wouldn't know it
by that big smile she was not smiling
when she showed up I said she showed up
so in character we thought she hated us
my first thought when I when I when I
said - hello - Jessica was I haven't
seen her in eight years how did I piss
her off I just I don't I don't know I
just really kind of connected with the
dark side of Nancy and it was hard to
detach from that until until the movie
was over yeah and really you know the
whole time I was in Austin I stayed
connected - yeah - that spirit I don't
know what else nothing would break it
we'd make jokes you wouldn't laugh
nothing to help I thought but there and
I felt like I was also just more mature
you know in the first one I was in my
early 20s I was just trying to figure it
out I was so intimidated just being in
your world I mean in Austin it's kind of
an intimate intimidating world
you don't know how sweet and warm and
awesome you are and Frank you know you
kind of intimidating Frank oh my god
rise surprised you know I was like just
try to figure it out but the second time
you know I I felt comfortable I felt
like a woman I felt comfortable in my
own skin
and and I wanted to kick ass yeah one of
the great transformations and then this
movie in the series of films it starts
with this innocent little girl in the
first film and when you see when she
becomes by the end of this it's it's
pretty breathtaking so you're in for a
surprise
just I don't know this so forgive me if
did you get to do a lot with powers
booth on the set they exist before words
in this movie I think that is going to
he is one scary mofo he is it makes me
nervous
really so even I watched the movie with
him this movie with him and I it's hard
to even look no and I know he was like I
have a company and he uses my baby diet
my company's diapers on his grandkid but
in all this and I just I wanted to run
away he's so intimidating he's he's
really good in this and Eva Green I mean
she is one scary woman yeah she is
capable of everything Robert when did
you two talk a little bit about some of
the cast members there aren't years
getting their performances Joseph
gordon-levitt just gordon-levitt oh he's
so
exciting part was we knew after the
first film women were making the first
film we knew we'd do Damon to kill for
next because that was the book we
skipped when we were adapting the other
stories it was it was just too long of a
book to try and squeeze it into the
first film and Frank right away said you
know that would be better as a sequel it
would answer some of the questions of
you know some of these characters we
gave that it's due and we wanted to
surround it with some other stories like
you saw part of just another Saturday
night but then thought let's give the
audience something they can't just go to
the you know comic book store and buy a
book and know what's gonna happen
already let's Surprise them with some
new stories and I think that was the
most exciting was being part of Frank's
writing process he would start telling
me about this character named Johnny and
I would put on my tape recorder and
slide it over and be like listening and
that's how it was started to be written
out and he'll be drawing another great
thrill scene Frank Miller draw original
storyboards on the set because we don't
have a graphic novel to go with those
stories so all those shots had to be
created and he would draw them sometimes
ahead of time sometimes right on the set
and it was just a thrill you know I'm
getting to work with someone like Joseph
gordon-levitt and create this character
with with Frank and and build up a new
story that feels like it would fit right
in with all the other stories that that
was exciting there's one moment I have
to mention about drawing the storyboards
Nesta there was a shot of Jessica that I
had drawn where she was
well I won't get it anyway but she was
in an action pose and I true the way I
draw I mean it's it's it's it's not what
we call realistic not nothing real and I
looked over at her on stage and she
wasn't exactly the pose that I drew and
he was an impossible pose and I said
what are you doing how are you getting
like that she said that's what you drew
and that was the end of the conversation
we're all there to fulfill your vision
frame was one thing I wanted to ask you
about it is technology when you were
talking about it's kind of interesting
that you wear so many different hats
first of all hey you do so many things
when you were pushing your phone over to
record oh yeah you also you also tell me
oh yeah well the technology changed a
lot in the last 10 years I mean we that
was really early days of digital you
know I had done that what was I think
the first digital 3d movie just before I
did since city was called spike its 3d
and it was the cameras were like you
know this big this time we had Jim
Cameron Vince based latest cameras right
off the factory line they're like
Ferraris I mean they didn't slow us down
and all were able to shoot very very
fast to keep actors in the mode and the
technology was really great
another thing technologically that's
that that wasn't there 10 years ago was
there was these smartphones I got to
write the score again I didn't think I
would get and one of the favorite things
about the movie is Sin City was the
score its whole film or score you never
get to write music like that and I was
really afraid I had a lot going on this
year I didn't think I'd have the time to
sit and my music machine and make music
but these things are God said I'll tell
you how most of the music was written
I'd be like asleep in bed and I would
turn on just the built-in app that as a
recorder and I would hum in you know
half asleep I'd think of like a scene of
music no what we were filming it be like
vintage Intendant okay on top of that
robbers and you are not well
and then go back to sleep the next day
I'd go to my music station play it back
and go what the hell is that
now listen to it I would work it out in
the keyboard and that would be the score
80% of the score was written on the
phone first and then translate now it
bring it to set the next day and Jessica
would be acting to it say can you play
that score again and and it was really
cool just how far technology is able to
capture an idea you know and and help
you help facilitate those things so
you're really fun in this car the
contradiction in that is - is that
because you do so many things alone it
allows you to do an almost ultimate
collaboration and because you have so
much technology to apply you can get
back to doing things like doing a sketch
on a set yeah you know for the scene I
mean it's interesting to get closer
while getting further away and using
technology to get more authentic that's
kind of intriguing well from an artist
point of view I mean I try to move
pretty fast on a set frankly even more
impatient we'd be filming I'd be moving
really quick and he would be there was
any low let go shoot damn it shoot damn
it because it's he's an artist too you
know you take a piece of paper you grab
a pen and in ten minutes you have
something that didn't exist before
there's an immediacy to creating that
quickly that movies are slower or slower
than that and and it makes you quite
impatient so that's why I think we tend
to move very fast cuz we know creation
doesn't have to be a long process well
it were does it works both ways because
there were also times when I would come
up with a shot and I would be I would
just put down on maybe six lines just
beginning the drawing and then I get to
work on finishing drawing and I'd look
at the monitor and he'd already shot it
that's I could tell very clearly what
you're reframing by your drawings are so
distinct there's I guess that's gonna be
a head that's a shoulders and suggest a
low-angle let's we we have to keep
moving so I've set it up it was very fun
very fast spreader is a big box of
drawings that need to be on eBay here
like this
groans okay do you we're gonna take some
questions from the audience now I think
if you have any questions please step to
the microphone and remember that a
question ends in a question mark nope no
threats proposals itches I mr. Miller
it's an honor thank you I was wondering
your movies 300 and Sin City
thanks to mr. Rodriguez and Schneider
like these are the greatest translations
of comic books to movies like direct
translation and it's amazing do you
demand that mr. Miller or did you just
get lucky it's a very good question
because I I it was used because it was
never in question Robert started
intending to translate Sin City and and
Zack showed an immediate understanding
of what 300 was about and the
adjustments he made were quite small so
it's never really been an issue now I
get real prick I'll clarify one thing I
mean one thing for sure I can tell you I
went and I showed Frank a test of Sin
City what I was gonna do what I am
planning to do it and that he would come
along he controlled the rights to Sin
City I know for a fact he would not have
done the movie had I not done it that
way because when I first even proposed
you know doing it he said that sounds
really exciting but oh then we got to
write a script and we submit it to a
studio and they're gonna give us no and
if he was asked to go through the
traditional filmmaking process even if
they promised a lot of freedom he
wouldn't have done it it was his baby
why why go do that and so I think that
in a way he didn't demand it but he I
certainly certainly would not have gone
in that journey if it was gonna be the
same song and dance that he'd been
through before he wouldn't have done it
basically question no matter how much
they paid him how's it going oh hi Jeff
Aron Kai's my name oh yeah you guys
really Rock
Robert I just wanna say it was really
cool meeting you of the other night at
the Sin City Hard Rock party and Frank
mr. Miller and Robert your your vision
Frank with your graphic novel and Robert
with your expertise and the cast
inspired me to hand paint this jacket
back in 2008 the movie I got was Ariel I
have you here okay work there we go and
I have delayed Michael Clarke Duncan and
Brittany Murphy every no he's four nice
and hand-painted excellent excellent
Jimbo's awesome yeah I'm sorry you a
question it was the question yeah my god
my question is is Frank mr. Miller I
recently saw the documentary to Central
Park five and one of the sergeant's in
that documentary was named John Hartigan
and he was a detective and he was tall
and had that looked like one of your
characters and I was wondering you know
you being from New York like myself
that was one inspiration of your
characters for the UH for the graphic
novel no actually I named hardigan after
a childhood friend of my brothers
so it's complete coincidence and your
brother's here right yeah that's nice
um yeah but it was nothing wrong my
father died I have almost as many as he
has hey how's it going hi I just want to
say it's a real honor to be in front of
all of you guys Frank and Robert and
Rosario and Josh Brolin and Jessica Alba
like you guys are amazing thank you guys
um my questions for ya there's though
I'm dealing with a movie like like this
when you guys have to deal with green
screens a lot what did you guys have to
do to work in your carriage of a
character development before the film to
get the characters just right and stay
in that character I'm so distracted by
the America's Most Wanted I know I'm
sorry I would never
you guys were used to it no it's it's I
think it's tough
I worked with an acting coach and before
I went and then I and I worked with a
choreographer and I I had to get into
the head of of Nancy
I mean I'm nothing like this girl so I
really had to connect with that
psychotic dark side it was really fun
but it was a lot of work prior to going
for me at least Josh know I feel like a
total fraud right now mm-hmm
showed up he said the lines even I feel
like I need the therapy I know I live
years before I started this film I lived
with Frank for three years and yeah so
everything with you when you show up at
a green screen and you know you've heard
they say at least for me who hadn't done
it and you heard the stories about the
original Sin City and what was the song
that Mickey would play that was Mickey
making me play one song with all the
hurt the the Johnny Johnny Cash the nail
to get in the mode you know and we all
want to be Mickey and we want to have a
song you know mine was like Lady Gaga's
but it's really strange when you first
get into it it's a it's definitely a
leap of faith and then once you're in
about two or three days when you're
really only working for a week how long
did we work for maybe a we were there
only about a week I better uh comment
though that one thing that I found to be
at least to my to my limited experience
is it was amazing was that the the lack
of a background actually seemed to
increase the energy between the actors I
could focus on one of the most memorable
scenes in in in in the first Sin City
was between Jessica and Bruce Willis
where she was professing her love to him
and there are on accounts together and
the only thing there was the couch and
then and and and the the intensity they
brought were so great they were able to
shoot the entire thing close up it's
working I was just pretty withdrawn
another thing you do to really help the
actors for inter-process like this has
really get them to trust their instinct
Oh sometimes they're acting with nobody
else there and you want them to get to a
place where they just let go
and-and-and trust the process so in
between takes I I was set up in the back
of paint studio where I would teach them
all to paint even if they don't think
they know how to paint they would paint
we'd go back and they would do a
painting of their character portrait of
their character that we would do
together as a co-creating of a character
just so that they would free themselves
up and see that if they just did worked
instinctually they could create
something that with using abilities they
didn't know they had innately and it
would and it would open them up so in
between takes
Josh would have run back and paint his
portrait which we'll have we'll start
showing around the time this movie's
release and everybody did rosario did
two amazing ones and of course they
never painted it before well when they
get to that place so then when they get
to the set and you're in front of a
green screen
they've already been solving problems
creatively and they're told to perform
and act and they can feel like they can
do anything because they've just been
you know immersed in that sort of
creative environment that's one thing we
do to really kind of help just get
people in this mode where they they
don't think about what they don't know
they think about what they do know what
they well in another example of what I
was talking about was that there's a
very intense scene between Clive Owen
and Rosario which takes place during
driving rain in the movie and in it um
he takes her gun away and she kisses him
but she doesn't just kiss him she
practically rips his head off and and I
can only wonder if we would have gotten
exactly that moment if there'd been rain
batting on their faces in their eyes and
and and and confusing everybody on the
set instead the rain was completely
digital you know it was it was to try
and said yeah the use of colour in the
film is is done a lot of in post once we
think about because we shoot the whole
thing in colour we strip away all the
colour and then slowly very
strategically we start putting it back
in places even where it wasn't in the
books just to see if it could highlight
an idea or bring across to do a little
bit more of a stir a layer of
storytelling using the colour so you'll
see a use of colour different in this
movie but more involved than even in the
first film hey there how are you doing
good are you Jeff might even detect a
burrito
I'm an actor writer and I'm also a huge
fan of everybody on the panel um Robert
and Frank your movies are great I love
the old Murray watching movies The Spy
Kids movies and your daredevil run was
just insane it's my favorite the stuff
you've done a Sin City is so amazing I'm
wondering if maybe you guys are gonna
get together and maybe do another
project like Ronan wrote in the be great
the DC Comics the 1982
yes you catch the snoring mood I mean as
far as Sin City goes on Robert and I are
already talking about since 83 so you
better show up for number 2 or else they
won't pay for it we're still chance to
be Nancy still believe me either
you have a question where is that dude
what is that can I have some my question
is for its rank first of all I just want
to say that you're one of my favorite
writers and artists ever written some of
the best and draughts of the best my
question is that with lease of Sin City
ii dame to kill for if there's any plans
for another Sin City graphic novel
inevitably it's it's where I would want
to go for my crime stories be the you
know right now I'm and work on other
things but i I've always got you know
I've got to stack up stories but I want
to do so I would say yes but what ye are
not sure hello how are you I'm doing
well thanks I my question first is for
mr. Rodriguez because obviously between
the first Sin City and now we
unfortunately lost Michael Clarke Duncan
and of course we had you had to recast
that role and he owned the role of
Manute a so well that I just couldn't
picture anyone else in that part so I
was just wondering what went into your
consideration in recasting that role and
quick question to mr. Miller is there
any chance we'll get to see Martha
Washington on the big screen nice I'll
answer first Martha Washington on the
big screen Martha Washington somewhere I
think it will happen but it's got to be
done right and like I said this time I'm
gonna be a prick it's gonna be done my
way
terrific Robert this is a great question
both great questions as far as Michael
you know what the common thread they're
both of those is that everybody wants to
be very true to Frank's material Michael
Clarke was very true to the material
came in and created a great part after
his passing Dennis Haysbert who knew you
know Michael was friends with him came
in to take the torch and and continue it
and and since it's a prequel it actually
works really well what Michael did and
Dennis is stunning in this movie you're
gonna be very pleased with what he did
he really paid tribute to Michael and
also created something unique and it's
gonna make you one more I mean he really
is a standout and it takes a real artist
and real gentleman to come in and do
that for his friend and for the sea
franchise and also to stay true to what
Frank created in the first place you
know it takes some times as many people
to play one amazing part and we all kind
of signed a book my boy before and
wanted to give it out to a great
question that was a great question so
we're gonna give this to you a little
bit from from Sin City ten years ago
before we run out of time we might still
I get your question we showed a scene
from the movie and then we showed sort
of a montage showing some of the
drawings compared to the film and this
was actually Jessica's idea one of the
songs she she had planed while she
danced one of her amazing dances on on
during the film was a song called the
song is called babes but I think you'll
know it was killer babes but you know he
blossoms and we cut a montage just to do
that she said why don't you cut him on
touch to that song we tried it and it
worked amazing so you to get you a
little more of the footage in a montage
we got a little clip for you so check
this out thank you all for coming
the city would know the next time for
part three since
hey guys we'll see you next time thanks
hall age you guys are the best ladies
and gentlemen once again let's hear it
for Frank Miller's Sin City a dame to
kill for with our co directors Robert
Rodriguez Frank Miller rosario Dawson
Josh Brolin and Jessica Alba and our
special guest moderator mr. Geoff
Boucher
okay I'll be damned if it takes us nine
years next time
you